tract steps but no screen screen but
this is an eyesore and constant
notifications yeah my Dick Tracy costume
is ready for Halloween hmm this might
work this is Samsung's much-anticipated
Galaxy gear fit and it aims to do with
the rest of these high-tech bracelets
haven't been able to do combined fitness
tracking and SmartWatch capabilities
into a design you'd actually want to
wear the $200 bracelet has a beautiful
curved touch screen and works with
Samsung phones to give you your text
messages and email notifications right
on your wrist but trying to be all of
those things hold the fit back from
being the perfect fit of all the
trackers I've worn in the past year the
gear fit has attracted the most
attention
hey that's bracelet and that's because
it's the coolest looking the design is
clean and the Super AMOLED display is
beautiful with great viewing angles and
unlike many others it's easy to put on
that set it's relatively thick and bulky
on a small wrist like mine it's also
water-resistant I've been wearing it in
the shower for the last week and it's
been a ok
hashtag is showering and surprisingly
and possibly a first for Samsung the
clean Hardware design is matched with
fairly clean software design you can
customize the main screen and change the
wallpapers you can even crop a photo and
use that I'm watching you get it and
then you get a list of apps and features
you can even program this button to
launch your favorite apps so you don't
have to go looking for it
so you don't actually have to press the
button to turn on the screen you can
just lift it up and it should turn right
on but there are some drawbacks
especially when it comes to fitness
tracking capabilities sometimes it
registers body movements as steps and
doesn't accurately record the number of
steps I've taken and my testing I found
that the jawbone up24 and other fit bits
have been way more accurate in terms of
recording those steps and then there's
the heart rate monitor which is on the
other side of the bracelet it only works
though if you keep your arm really
straight not really convenient when
you're working out then sometimes it
takes so long to find my pulse that I
wonder am i alive but my biggest issue
with the fit is the s health app which
allows you to see your fitness data on
your Samsung phone the app design is
very confusing and cluttered it's just
hard to figure out what you're looking
at Fitbit and jawbone have far better
looking apps and also provide deeper
info about your activity battery life is
another weakness for the fit lasting
about two days with smart phone
notifications turned on charging is a
pain you need to clip this little thing
on and that means not losing it the
SmartWatch functionality is slightly
better but no one has quite mastered the
notifications on a wrist thing yet text
messages and phone call notifications
are good and you can even respond right
from the device with a few preset
messages but there's very little control
for alerts from third-party apps if you
get the notification on your phone you
get it on your wrist still it's very
helpful to just glance down at a screen
instead of having to take your phone out
and Samsung has done a nice job with how
the phone app works with the fit the fit
does combine the best of the fitness
tracking and SmartWatch world but it
doesn't do either of those things
particularly well right now you can buy
a number of fitness trackers like the
jawbone up24 for fifty to a hundred
dollars less than the fit and they have
an edge on fitness tracking then there
are a host of other promising new
smartwatches on the way the fit is a
leap forward for Samsung but it's still
not the perfect fit and imbedding come
the end of this year there's going to be
a lot better options in this box